erica is in Houston Erica your question
for Chris Hogan hi good afternoon to
both of you and so Chris my question is
we're very very new listening to both of
you so we've done some things wrong so
my question is just like that study
we're in a panic
we're 33 we're making about 280 a year
and we could 8% towards retirement only
since 2012 so we've got about maybe 60 K
in there we pay off our house but we've
done kind of the baby steps backwards we
didn't know about them so we want to be
able to retire early but just how do we
go from here we still have about 70 K on
cars with perches that we can cash out
you know today as we need to just my
husband has a disagreement with me on
that because I'm very sure on what what
was that you can write a check and pay
off the cars today out of what um just
the cash so we're sitting on okay
all right great okay well Erica I would
tell you this you know number one you've
paid off your home you've got a big
shovel with two hundred eighty thousand
dollars in income and you're in your 30s
so what I want to tell you is this and I
want you to hear me take a collective
deep breath do it for me
there we go because that's what needs to
happen because when you breathe now you
can start to get oxygen flowing and you
can focus so what I would do is you and
your husband need to sit down have a
dream date get on the same page of what
you're chasing I love the fact that
you've attacked that we've got 70,000
and card debt that needs to get out of
your life because it's stealing from you
and now you're investing 8 percent of
your income we need to get that up to 15
you see the baby steps are proven so I
want you to follow them take a look at
them I'm going to send you a copy of my
book but you and your husband getting on
the same page sitting down with a smart
best or pro you all are young you have
time and trust me you can build a legacy
see here's the thing what you guys have
tried to do Erica I try to do it for
years I'm gonna pick a chit but so hold
on tight okay
you tried you've tried to out-earn your
stupidity yes and I tried to do it you
can't do it you have to have a plan and
you have to have a set goal what Chris
is talking about with a dream date where
you say okay where do we want to be in
five years we make two stinking much
money to be broke and to have this knot
in my stomach
okay and so write a check today and pay
off the cars have an emergency fund set
aside of three to six months of expenses
be putting 15% of your income away and
then start doing some other investing
and in addition to that and you max out
everything in that situation because
you're dead free you have your emergency
fund in place you're sitting on cash
you're making so much money you only
know what to do with it and that's
giving you anxiety am i wrong yet yeah
and I think he opposes to paying off the
cars because he says that you know
they're they're good tomorrow ahead and
we're going to total those cars we lost
all that cash that was put in there
because we could put that towards some
sort of those listen that's just plain
stupid
okay I mean for somebody making as much
money he's pretty dumb yeah he likes the
idea Dave of looking and feel better I
don't know I don't know what he does but
here's the thing if those cars were paid
for he wouldn't go borrow on them to put
money in the bank would he know so his
logic completely breaks down this is
just straight-up dumb so it's stupid you
don't borrow on your cars to build
wealth and create and create a quality
life with no anxiety you pay those off
today you don't have any payments in
your whole freakin life
Wow that's called financial peace two
words that don't go together like
Airlines service right there and so
that'll get you started you've got all
the tools you got a big enough shovel
but you desperately need a plan that the
two of you agreed to and you're not
going to use card debt to build wealth
no absolutely it is and they need that
fully funded emergency fund so you can
look at that and keep score and Dave
here's the thing I want to tell them in
their 30s be careful of going to look at
stuff if going to look causes you to buy
then stop looking okay cuz he sounds
like he's got car or truck item no he's
just trying to think she thinks he's
outsmarting a bank by borrowing money on
a car and then saving money at 1% of
stupid savings account it's just
backwards don't do it don't don't try to
do that stuff just be debt-free and
invest like crazy people and you're
going to be so wealthy you won't be able
to
see and their income is going to
continue to go up which means they can
invest even more hopefully hang on Kelly
I'll send you out a copy of the book
retire inspired because I heard Chris
give one away just now hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you can do
this you know that really is a message
whether you got two hundred seventy
thousand dollars in student loan debt or
twenty seven thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a five
hundred thousand dollar income